now those that have drank the Kool-Aid
whatever you guys can burn in hell if
you want that's up to you but for those
that want to know the truth you know
that makes no sense you know it makes no
sense to say they're equal but one is
lower than Angels one is greater than
everybody else you know that doesn't
make any sense anyway can we're gonna
get can I step in hey hey don't don't
don't run away man don't don't go
nowhere now don't it's my turn now yeah
I just I just want I just wanted I just
wanted to touch on something you said a
little bit earlier and this a little bit
too so you you so you mentioned how you
don't believe you don't go to the Bible
to show that Jesus is a Muslim but I
don't but you but you have in many of
your videos and I literally have one
you're you're with you're exp you're
with wa let me just explain what
happened okay you literally said that
even the Bible shows that Jesus is a
Muslim and that because he prayed to the
father and and uh and you said that you
pray to the same God that Jesus prayed
cuz he prayed to his father you said
that in the video that yes you did I
literally have it on my Chanel what I
said go ahead do you want me to explain
it did you ask a question or well no I I
just made a statement so so okay yeah so
what's your question so so if you're
saying that you don't go to the Bible to
show that Jesus is a Muslim why did you
go to the Bible in your earlier videos
when you talk to other Christians who
are not really that knowledgeable and
you quote the Bible how Jesus prayed
prostrating how he said he's doing the
will of the father to show them that he
submitted to God and that he's a Muslim
from the Bible
are you done with your question yes are
you going to interrupt me I I promise
I'm won't all I appreciate that okay if
you ask me why do I believe Jesus is a
Muslim it's not based on the Bible my
belief is based on the Quran as you know
because we've discussed this many a
times I don't believe the Bible is
preserved I don't believe it's the word
of God I don't believe in the Bible but
if you're a Christian and you believe in
the Bible then I will ask you that even
according to your scripture if it shows
Jesus praying to God according to the
Bible the father right if it shows Jesus
saying that the father's greater than I
if it shows Jesus saying it's not my
will but yours then even according to
your belief according to your
understanding if you're Christian then
it shows that Jesus was worshiping a God
above right but that's not why I believe
it do you understand the difference
there yeah I believe
let let me finish I believe it because I
believe in the Quran I believe in Islam
I don't believe in the Bible but if you
come to me as a Christian and you say
you believe in the Bible then if I show
you something in your book that your
belief has then that doesn't mean that
I'm using it for my belief when he asked
me the question to prove to me why do I
believe Jesus is a Muslim I'm not going
to quote the Bible although I would say
that you as a Christian should see that
in the Bible Jesus did pray to the God
above right okay so I understand what
you're saying you're saying that you
don't believe that Jesus is a Muslim
based off what the Bible says you
believe it because of what the Quran
says I understand your position my my
thing is this is that when you talk to
Christians you're showing you're saying
that even according to the Bible Jesus
is a Muslim and you you quoted the
verses that you quote now here's my
question with this okay when you quote
these verses and you obviously you see
that Jesus prays to the father he
submits his will to the father he was
sent by the father he's the son of the
father right my question is this can you
be a Muslim and believe that you are the
son of
Allah I do not believe that Jesus
believed that God was his father okay
when I show those verses I am not saying
that I believe that Jesus said that my
point is that if you believe in the
Bible if you do then you see in your own
Bible things that do not make from your
Trinity because if they're co-equal how
can one be calling the other my God and
worshiping the other according to you I
do not believe Jesus called God father
right now as I said earlier there maybe
a term of endearment was used as the
father but I would never think that
would be literal right in the sense we
have a mu called right we may say Al the
father because of his status and
knowledge but none of us would be stupid
enough to think he's literally Our
Father you understand yeah so in that
could Aramaic have had that context
maybe I don't know and I don't claim to
know okay but I would agree that
biblically there are people called gods
for example in the Old Testament when
you see the the son the sons of God and
then God being a judge amongst Gods
which I think me and you would both
agree don't refer to God as being the
all powerful right yeah so I like again
those are Linguistics right well it's
not it's not it's not just never oh go
ahead sorry oh okay go ahead all right
yeah so like I like I said I understand
completely your position and I know that
you don't believe the words of Jesus in
the Bible my my point is right right
right my point is this U man is that you
when you talk to the Christians you say
that even according to the Bible it
shows that Jesus meets the criteria of
being a Muslim based on the Bible even
though you don't believe in it you're
saying that as a Christian you you have
since you believe in these words these
words of Jesus show that he's a Muslim
right but so my question is based on
these words that Jesus says he is the
the son of the father right he does the
will of the father everything that the
father owns all also belongs to him all
these kind of things that he says right
can you be a Muslim and believe that you
are the son of
Allah as I just said I do not believe
that son and father here would refer to
a biological relationship for example
let me let me okay good so for example
if those terms were used as Terms of
Endearment in the language I I can
understand that that could be possible
Right But as a Muslim we clarify that
Allah has no children
right now like I said in linguistics at
times I can talk to somebody and say son
come listen to me but if somebody comes
and says that that means you have a
biological son in this person or you're
physically children then I would say no
no no no you don't understand what we
mean here right now when I say that look
at the aspects of servitude of Jesus to
the God above right that doesn't mean
that those vers in the in the verbage
that it is used are going to be used by
me for my credal belief yeah right
meaning in the sense that if G like for
example in the Bible Jesus did say the
father is greater than I right y right
so now as a trinitarian when you say
they're equal but Jesus says the father
is greater than I for me to point out
that that doesn't make sense right the
Bible does say that Jesus became lower
than the Angels right oh yeah that but
that's not the issue here the issue is
is not the deity of Christ about his
religion that when I point out that even
Biblical verses go against the Trinity
and show Jesus as a servant of the God
above now what words are that's a
trinitarian
belief the traran belief is that God God
and Jesus are not equal uh in Authority
that the father that he submits to the
father's Authority so that's not a
that's not a a issue when it comes to
trinitarian belief and it's not an issue
it's not it's not it's not relevant to
whether when we're asking about how what
did Jesus believe and if his belief in
his practices followed like under the
criteria of being a musliman like that's
what that's what I'm asking when you say
Let me let me just say this let me say
this please if I can please go okay so
when you when you say I appreciate it so
when you say that um like maybe it could
have been used in a term of endearment
you know you don't know right you're not
giving a statement you don't know you're
saying it could be so my my question is
this like within Islamic
theology was Allah ever a father in any
sense the term of endearment
metaphorically was he ever a
father once again if you're talking
about Islamic theology it's based in the
Arabic language right uh sure these
words have
meaning what yeah yeah yeah I mean yeah
it's Arabic but these I mean it has
meaning it has theology so again
languages have difference in meanings
right for example when in Arabic we say
AMU for an uncle right you understand
what I'm sure how we use that context
will differ in the Arabic language in
context father has been used for respect
but for yeah but is that is the word
father in Arabic used for Allah oh sorry
let me explain it to you so you can
listen I know you don't want the answer
now so no no no I'm following you I I
didn't mean to cut you off my bad go
ahead thank you so as Terms of
Endearment go the word father for
example I gave you even in Arabic
context can be used for even a scholar
right meaning they would say right
yeah for example Lam was called the
father to the daughters of lot not
literal fathers right we would never
utilize that for Allah because of the
fact that the sh that had happened
clarified that to us okay in Islamic
Arabic language we wouldn't okay but
could it again let me finish in the
earlier Nations right when they didn't
have that fear could they have used an
Aramaic term that would be later transl
in Greek which are your original
manuscripts right I I can't speak to
that but I can say that in Islam today
we would never call God our Father m
because of the fact that the sh that
came out can having said that let me
finish because having said that having
said that I'm not saying Jesus used
exact those words in my belief but as a
Christian if you're saying that Jesus
submitted right then we would say that
if he humbled himself and made a servant
yep right then that would not make him
God I understand your I understand your
argu I understand your argument it
doesn't so I don't agree with it but I
understand your argument so but this is
what I'm this is what I'm dealing with
okay you not agree with that that's
interesting right I'll show you I'll
show you in a second let me
respond let me respond please because
Ser servitude and servitude has nothing
to do with ontology uh that's just to do
with role your status like for example
you you you serve you serve your let me
come on brother you serve I'm listening
I just want to understand okay yeah you
serve your boss at work you're under you
you to your boss's Authority at work yet
you guys are both human so you're equal
in in nature because you guys are both
human yet you he you're great your boss
is greater than you because he has a
higher status than you in the workplace
so having a higher status is not the
same as uh being more valuable or
greater ontologically but I want resp
not not not just yet not just yet I
wanted to say something to the to the
father things stillo because there's
still some things that are not clear
that I'm not getting a direct answer on
I feel so you said that you can you know
refer to like certain Scholars or people
of um you know I guess high regard with
these terms right um and and
metaphorically you can do it right
linguistically and metaphorically you
can do it um now my question is now see
I know that you don't call Allah father
but I'm I'm asking right but I'm asking
can you identify Allah as a father as in
a term of respect and endearment even
though you know you're not using it in a
literal sense but you're using it
metaphorically that he loves you that
he's your caretaker can you call Allah a
father in that
sense look again I I I've made this
clear but maybe you're not getting so
I'm going to make it I'm gonna try one
more time all right let me see if you
can get it right that one's not being
answered
respectfully it is being answered but
maybe you're not listening but let me
try it again okay for example we say R
Lord to Allah
right Lord can be used for other than
Allah right but that doesn't mean that
we consider anybody else like Allah
understand okay so as I said in a
linguistic perspective can be used for
somebody out of endearment can it be
used for Allah we we would never right
why would we never because of the fact
that when people used it for sh we took
that Linguistics even and said no we
don't want to go there you understand
yeah
yeah not ask please don't interrupt
Islam we would never use the word up for
Allah right right having said that I'm
discussing it from an Arabic perspective
in our context now when we're talking
about the Bible obviously you know the
Bible was not an Arabic and you
understand the context of the language
of Aramaic was different but what I'm
making video explicitly clear today we
would never use the word for I know that
you would I I'm interrupt yes don't tell
me I'm not answering no because that's
not my question my question isn't would
you as a Muslim like my question is not
would you ever use this term for Allah
my that's not my question my question is
can you can I know that you wouldn't but
can you use the word AB for for Allah in
as a term of endearment are you talking
about in Arabic yes
what whatever yeah whatever language you
speak whatever right the word the word
AB means father listen the word father
has a lot to do with the language you're
speaking right for example when you
speak to a priest what do you call him a
Catholic
priest they refer to him as father yeah
father not you all right but Catholics
right yeah in my language in PTO a
Catholic priest could never be called
father okay you sure do you understand
the difference why yeah why not because
in PTO that would make absolutely no
sense
why what do you mean why I'm telling you
from PTO in the language PTO to call
somebody who's not your biological
father father cannot be done and PTO you
said your languag is p yeah I I'll check
that out but okay go ahead check it out
man right so when you're talking about
Aramaic and Arabic those are two
different languages right could Aramaic
use it could be but in Arabic we would
not okay I got you so so you're saying
that you don't have a you're saying that
you don't have a word that I guess can
um like the word father in Arabic cannot
be used figuratively for Allah right you
could be used for others maybe but not
for Allah in Islam so my my question is
this my question is my question is this
man so like when Jesus says that he is
the Son of God that he was sent into the
world World by God as his one and only
son his unique son right can he be can
someone say that and be a
Muslim so once again to respond to you
what language did Jesus speak spoke
Aramaic Hebrew and
Greek so in Aramaic could you use that
for endearment I don't know right you
don't speak Aramaic and I don't speak
Aramaic to be honest right I'm just I'm
you're not getting you're not getting my
question you're trying to run from my
answer no is it okay if I clarify no I'm
sorry is it okay if I
clarify do you speak Aramaic I I don't
but it's okay if I clarify my question I
don't speak Aramaic either yeah so how
is inment used in Aramaic I don't know
there's no there's no different it does
there's no different word for for that
type of stuff no there's not they use
they use they use the word AB my brother
they used they used the word ABA they
used the word ABA in Aramaic the Jews
used for God and they meant it in in as
a term of endearment they're not literal
sons of God they don't believe that the
word was ABA that's used so my question
look my question isn't you know that
because we have the Lang we have we have
it in the scriptures we have their
language we have all of this so where
did you get that from from the Bible
give me a reference from the scripture
from the Bible no no the Linguistics you
said the Jews used it
for God or no no no no I'm saying that
they that they use the word ABA they
called they called God ABA in Aramaic
that's father and so they
don't oh yeah Jesus did it too yeah but
Bible's not in aric well no it has
Aramaic words in it you didn't know that
no no no but where where does Jesus use
Aramaic ABA in the Bible Mark chapter uh
uh Mark Chapter 14 verse 30 I think
six Mark what Mark
14:36 okay what is the verse it says
it's talking about where Jesus prayed in
the garden of Gethsemane and uh he went
prostrating and it and it says what he
says he said it went he went prostrating
fell in his face and said ABA father ABA
ptro if it be possible let this cut pass
from
me okay so now you're saying that this
is Aramaic for what that's Aramaic for
father that's Aramaic for
father is it endearment or literal well
well when Jesus is talking wait don't
don't interrupt me wait wait AB not why
are you interrupting
me you're lying interrup me is not Omar
what's happening Omar ABA is Omar you
guys let these guys up and you're
letting these dudes interrupt you're
letting these dudes interrupt
Omar
Omar come on tell him don't interrupt
don't interrupt please go ahead so go
ahead so so you're saying is this
literal or figurative so what I'm saying
is is that this is the only word
forefather now when Jesus said say it
obviously he's he I'm sorry you said
that's the only word in Aramaic for
father yes are you sure about that
yes have you checked that
yes and if you find other words in
Aramaic for father then then I'm I guess
I'm wrong but from what from what I've
seen from what I've seen that's the only
word for
father okay so there there there will be
different forms of it depending on how
the phrase of the sentence is like my
father it might be you know ABI or
or something like that but um ABA is
father in arama literally or
figuratively yes
yes say that again of in Aramaic of I I
don't know I don't know what that is but
so so this so this is so this is where
we're getting in aric there's also of
that means father can you show that for
father can you show that what can you
show that yeah bring it up on
the put on the
screen yeah let it let it
uh so the word is Aba the Aramaic term
for father is Aba so that's that's Abba
right there man the but but when
speaking yeah look but when speaking to
someone hold on let me read it let me
let me read it if you can
please oh the live is freezing up
guys it literally says Abba on the link
um I don't know what happened guys but
the live is Frozen like uan you're
Frozen I can't even hear you guys if you
guys can hear
me guys the live is lagging big
time it's possible their phone probably
died I'll try to stay here until uh
until
otherwise now unfortunately the
conversation ended uthman's phone died
and therefore the live got distorted and
had to and got shut down so we didn't
get to conclude on our discussion but I
thought it was worth me giving a proper
conclusion to this notice how they were
now questioning the word ABA and whether
the word ABA uh the word that Jesus used
for father is actually Aramaic and they
brought up something that where it
related it to the word of um but let's
actually see what the word a is so when
we go over here to uh logos logos.com
and and by the way I encourage everyone
to download Logos is a beautiful
database a lot of information on there a
lot of scholarly work the origins of ABA
Watch what it says here it says of
Aramaic origin right seen in Daniel 5 2
verse 11 13- 18 ABA parallels the Hebrew
word
of from where ABA or father is
derived so the word of that they were
bringing up saying oh well this is
actually another word for that this is
another word for father in Aramaic no
it's not Aramaic it's a Hebrew word it's
not Aramaic so so again point is that
Jesus used the word ABA Jews used the
word ABA now watch this here some
Scholars consider it to be a colloquial
term of
familiarity that a young child would
have used similar to how American
children use Papa or daddy jeho jeremias
a German Lutheran Theologian held that
ABA is a children's word used in
everyday talk and in and that it express
the heart of Jesus's relationship with
God right he writes Jesus spoke to God
as a child to as as a child to its
father confidently and securely and yet
at the same time reverently and
obediently so you see here that the term
father is was a colloquial term used by
those who spoke Aramaic and uh you know
it's an Aramaic word not a Hebrew word
the word a in Hebrew is it's different
from from ABBA but I want you guys to
pay attention to how this went down
notice umman would not answer the
question he kept repeating how we as
Muslims would not use the term father
for Allah we can use it for all these
other people and y y y we would not use
it for Allah now that wasn't my question
my question was can you can you as a
Muslim refer to Allah as a father even
in as a term of endearment not meaning
it literally but meaning it
metaphorically with respect and he would
not answer it he kept deferring to and
sticking his toes down on I we would not
do it he did he wouldn't answer if can
he because once he said no you can't do
it as a Muslim then he would have to
admit that according to the Bible Jesus
is not a Muslim and he's been lying to
Christians that he's been talking to for
years years at his tent so unfortunately
we didn't get to finish that
conversation um but I hope that you guys
enjoyed it make sure you guys take notes
um and make sure you subscribe get hit
the like button uh also give me hit me
in the comment section let us know uh if
uthman did answer the question and what
question would you have asked umman if
you were able to have this conversation
with him uh or what was the best part to
you I want to see all your thoughts in
the comment section
[Music]
peace oh my godic
n
[Music]